what is the difference between sexual
chemistry and infatuation what is the
difference between really hot sex and a
physical connection and having a crush
on someone because they're different
things I would say that sexual chemistry
is of the body sexual chemistry is
animality sexual chemistry is genetic
compatibility sexual chemistry is two
bodies that are meant to mate sexual
chemistry feels good sexual chemistry is
hot but it's also Airy it's flighty
sexual chemistry does not compel the
urge to secure or physical Allegiance
sexual chemistry can just be an
encounter it does not activate the
desire for possession sexual chemistry
gets off on its own temporariness sexual
chemistry is about the moment truly no
attachment it's hot it's groovy it's
great everyone should have it practice
safe sex but the sexual chemistry is all
good infatuation is a different animal
when you have a crush on someone that
person takes on special meaning in your
eyes romantic infatuation having a crush
is crack for her romantic right
I mean the minute a person takes on
special meaning you've essentially
archetype alized this person you've
inflated this person you've put this
person on a pedestal you've actually
made a religious problem out of an
interpersonal relationship Ernest Becker
talks about it in his book the denial of
death he says we deify our lovers we
turned them into gods and goddesses when
we become infatuated with a person we
make them to the status of a god and the
thing about a god is that a God can save
us a God promises absolution a God
promises redemption right she's like the
wind she's my salvation she is the Sun
infatuation is when seeing your
reflection in the iris of a lovers I
will make you tear up infatuation means
you want to set it to actual sad music
you want it to be pregnant with
melancholy because it is pregnant with
melancholy infatuation is about past
al-jalil of static for a future time
when she will no longer be here you know
you anticipate the impermanence you see
the loss before it's happened
infatuation is pregnant with anxiety
it's pregnant with sadness it's pregnant
with melancholy infatuation means you
need this person or you think you need
this person which is ultimately the same
thing love can't be romantic unless it's
pregnant with a little bit of I can't
live without you and if I can't live
without you oh my god and it feels so
good to be with you but you live also
with the terrifying possibility that
this person might abandon you or betray
you in which case you want to do
anything you can to secure this
Allegiance you promise you love me
forever
you promise you're never gonna stop
loving me you promise like you're never
ever ever gonna cheat on me or like look
at somebody else there's a big
difference right we've all felt this
before we've all had these maddening
crushes biochemically no different than
being addicted to cocaine it's very
different than just having sexual
chemistry I've had my share of wonderful
sexual encounters in my life I feel
blessed I feel grateful for some souls
that I have encountered and shared naked
time with sexy time without attachment
and it's been groovy and we're still
friends and they are wonderful women but
I've also had maddening infatuations
romantic crushes that have arrested by
body mind into a friend
zyy of addiction of romantic intensity
the kind that inspires all of the pop
songs and that we want to set to
melancholic piano music as we watch
vintage videos of this person and mourn
the inherent impermanence of our life
with them it's like my video existential
bummer true romantic infatuation is
pregnant with sadness it can't not be
and so the question remains right if you
what should one aspire to if one is
single and one wants to express one's
sensual and sexuality with another
person do you find a sexual chemistry
and enjoy it for what it is or do you
seek out infatuation and a nice heavy
crush and all of its glory even though
it will destabilize you I suppose only
you guys can answer that only you can
answer that
you